بتصرختبارات الحمض النووي الاختبارات
الجينيه لاكثر من سبب منها الكشف لاستبقي
عن طفرات المحتمله في الجينات التي يمكن
ان تتسبب في اضطراب الماء مثل السرطان
وغيره ويخضع لها الاشخاص اذا كانت اسرهم
لديها تاريخ من الاصابه بمرض المراثي
يمكن ان تظهر اختبارات الحمض النووي ايضا
الاصول العرقيه للاشخاص والمنطقه
الجغرافيه التي تعود لها سفرتهم الوراثيه
ورث سلسله النسب والاسلاف الفحوص السابقه
للولاده قد تكشف بعض انواع الترابات في
جينات الجنين مثل متلازمه داون ويتم عن
طريق اخذ عينه الدم من الام فحص المواليد
هو واحد من الاختبارات الاكثر شيوعا في
الولايات المتحده ويخضع له الطفل تحسبا
بوجود بعض الاضطرابات الجينيه مثل قصور
الغده الدرقيه وحينها تتم رعايته وبدء
علاجه على الفور جمع عينه الحمض النووي
تتم من خلال اللعاب او مسح الجزء الداخلي
من الخد ثم توضع تلك المسحه في وعاء نظيف
لكن بعض الحالات تستوجب سحب الدم ايضا
ويمكن الاعتماد على عينات من الاظافر
والشعر